hey everybody we just played three hours
of fallout 76 and we asked you guys both
on twitter and youtube to submit
your questions about the game because i
feel like a lot of people are still
want to know what this game is about so
we're gonna try and answer as
many of those as possible there's
definitely definitely a lot to unpack
here
with this game let's get right to it
yeah
[Music]
okay first up from seoul empress uh can
we in fact
train animals as as it was shown during
the noclip documentary
so um apparently that
no apparently no you cannot we couldn't
see any of that at all we asked the devs
and they said no
i'm not sure exactly what the noclip
dock is referring to it sounds like
that might have been some
miscommunication in terms of words
they were saying that they wouldn't do
it because of balance purposes right
this is a more survival oriented game
and uh you know having the perk to
basically sort of uh lessen the threat
of animals sort of defeats
the purpose of the game especially
because you could share that perk with
your party members so if the whole team
is like immune to all these animals yeah
it's gonna make the game
way too easy so the answer is no
unfortunately
slaps14 wants to know uh what can you do
passively with other players
examples shop and trade so yeah you can
totally trade with people
um there's even so you can do emotes
where you can kind of tell people
like hey i need help or like hey man
good job and one of them is like hey i'm
interested in trading
and you can go up to them and you can
trade with people yeah other than that
you can uh kill them
yeah um that's a big thing you know that
seems to kind of be the main two
interactions is like trading with people
partying up uh partying up and then
killing them
um seems like a lot more the
interactions are going to be based on
like direct communication
yeah with players so uh socialize and
you know just be wary of who you're
encountering exactly
obscure element says what does it look
like in the vault show us a room
okay
[Music]
this one's coming from spoopy survivor a
good name by the way
uh how's character creation um it's
pretty much how it was in fallout 4 but
um
they sort of uh made it a little more uh
sort of refined i guess you could say
yeah i'm sure they've added a couple
more beers
i couldn't tell you what beard was for
versus this game but it seemed just as
in-depth as that game there's tons of
like extra features you can add like you
know there's like
i don't know like 12 different scars
yeah yeah way more scars
a lot of you can put dirt on your face
yes i don't know if you could do that in
the other dirt and grime and like
lime all the pimples that went before
you get your rashes yeah you get real
gross and four and you get real gross in
this one too so
there you go yeah so uh this one's
coming from cake three
will there be proximity chad um it's
planned uh
for as a future uh release um yeah they
said it should be in the full launch yes
uh but uh we were
actually playing like using xbox live's
like sort of chat you know parts chat
party chat system so we did not
personally experience any proximity chat
but they say it will be in the full
launch of this yes
just wants to know is there full frontal
nudity like todd promised
i'm not sure when todd howard ever
suggested that but uh we took all our
clothes off in the game and uh
in the game in the game
[Music]
max wants to know uh if there are any
vehicles in the game uh no
no um there's definitely a bunch of like
ruined like destroyed vehicles just like
other
real bummer there's a golf course and i
found like a ruined golf cart yeah
so badly wanted to drive it it was like
a prime opportunity to you know get us
to drive around yeah
no no vehicles nope uh it'd be too rocky
of a terrain i think to make them work
the way they designed it
what grind he wants to know what are the
guns like so pretty much
a lot of the guns were guns right from
fallout 4 so i think you're pretty
familiar with them
didn't really encounter anything too new
one of the high-level people had a
tesla gun yeah that seemed really
powerful he destroyed
the entire party with that gun too um
but other than that it seems like
they're uh they're definitely adding a
lot more variety there were like some
pump action shotguns that i don't
remember from
uh four or anything like that uh there's
definitely different variations of like
the female
familiar like uh sort of pistols
shotguns
so uh yeah the guns and shooting
mechanics are basically how they were in
fallout 4 but just
with a number of different yeah subtle
differences i'll say there was a good
variety
from the three hours we played i felt
like i was just encountering new new
weapons
all the time so martin asks can you
actually play solo
you can play solo but uh you'll always
be within the online world with other
players
yeah so uh you know even though you can
basically do your own thing like you
know and
probably not see a player for a while
but eventually you'll
come across another player you know
whether they'll be
you know hostile or friendly you know is
up to up to them really
but uh you can totally like you know do
your own thing like you know just
play in solitude right we got a lot of
questions from people about uh how the
game works solo play and to kind of
answer that broadly
it felt like you could play the game
solo for the most part like we were able
to do all the
story quests and the side quests um by
ourselves we just kind of said hey we're
going to leave our party for a bit and
play that way
and we were able to do it fine there
does seem to be certain
quests that are party specific there was
one that said
we needed to have like a full party to
actually like
activate but that seems like that's a
rarity that most of the quests you can
just kind of do on your own
so if you uh you're interested in just
playing the game solo it's totally
possible yeah
this one's coming from synthwave without
npc based missions how do you keep the
game from going stagnant
well you actually get missions from
various holotapes but also you encounter
some uh
various uh gusty bots like from the
vault yeah
yeah there are lots of robots wandering
around that do um
also like talk to you in some form so um
you know
while you're doing those sort of
missions like you'll actually gain like
you know new intel
like from diaries or dire entries uh
holotapes um you know
other various notes that you'll find you
know just like scattered around yeah
a lot of the quests seem to be designed
around uh you find a dead person
and then you find a thing on them that
activates a quest where you sort of
discover
how this person died seems to be like
one of the major
types of quests in this game you
basically
find new opportunities by sleuthing like
you know just sort of exploring the
environment
right so there's definitely less
um dialogue based quests you're not
going to get many of those
it's a lot more investigative um
like immersive type of questions so it
seems to be what they're going for in
this one yep
this one's coming from phil what does
the pip boy do
uh the pip boy is the pit boy from
fallout 4 and fallout 3 station's the
exact same pretty much
there were very minor changes they added
a specific menu for like the holotapes
this time because that's a more
prominent that's the way you get quests
in this game
um you could hit the uh the back button
yeah and it would make like a
transparent version of the pip boy that
is like cleaner
and i think that sort of designed
similar to the
sort of the power armor right exactly i
think they kind of did that
because it strips away from the ui but
then also it is
you can like still see behind you which
is very important because
it doesn't pause anymore with the pip
boy but otherwise i mean the pip boy it
functions the exact same
uh the the map is no longer on the
pip-boy yes uh the map is activated by
hitting the start button yeah yeah
then that's activated at any time so you
don't need to pull out the pip boy to
you know cycle through the menus just to
see the map just to see the map yeah
yeah
starbrew says i'm mainly concerned about
rpg elements and actual role playing
and since it can be played online how
much of role-playing will the game allow
you to do for example can you be
rewarded for playing a sheriff of the
server and kill real players
who play as bandits so i mean we only
got three hours so it's kind of hard to
tell the exact
limits of it um i mean theoretically you
you can you know you can make a your own
like settlement area and then players
could make
a couple settlements nearby and you
could potentially theoretically start
your like own town kind of if you wanted
and
you could you know you i could see
people getting really deep into the role
playing
as far as the systems that the game it
doesn't seem like the game has a bunch
of systems in place to
like facilitate that stuff but it
doesn't seem like it has limitations to
prevent you from
just doing it yourself yeah so i can see
people uh especially once private
servers become a thing making their own
like
private role-playing servers um but yeah
i think you'll be able to at least get
some interesting role-playing
experiences out of this game
especially in the later half of the game
um after it's been released for a while
i think a lot of people are going to
start doing that kind of stuff
mqdb asks how are vats in this game
that's kind of weird it took some
getting used to
it does take some bit getting used to so
it doesn't function
it doesn't slow down anymore it's all
real time
and essentially it just when you when
you activate it
the uh it takes away aiming from you
it'll auto aim towards the enemy
and then you just have a number that's
just constantly like shifting
shifting as they're moving around and
then you just kind of hit the button and
you're it
just kind of auto targets yeah it's sort
of like uh that scene in robocop where
he's just sort of like
he gets that overlay and the targeting
like over goes exactly um there were
perk cards that seemed to affect vats
like we got one that
added um the ability to target specific
limbs and stuff like that so it seems
like they're
potentially maybe that that's gets more
complex
yeah as you add more perk cards to it
but it never
goes away from real time then that's the
big thing that people are gonna have to
get used to you're gonna have to get
used to the way it behaves i found
myself
using it more occasionally and sticking
with um regular gunplay because i felt
confident in my accuracy but
if it's if you like the idea of letting
the computer shoot for you like
vast is still is still a thing yeah this
one's coming from cad
is the map full of fun and interesting
locations uh yeah i would say so
um i mean we only gotta play the game
for three hours so we didn't get
experience
everything but compared to like four and
three you know
there was just like a greater variety
yeah for sure you got like
lush forests uh you got like this ski
resort mountain we climbed up you got
the um
the greenbrier here uh which was like
had like a
perfectly lush like golf course uh
maintained by like robots like
they definitely are kind of going all
out there with like weird locations and
it felt
it just felt more interesting to walk
around and then i felt like four did at
times or
felt a little samey yeah it definitely
feels a lot more like an amusement park
in a way like
there's very specific areas that are
like you know hey this is
where this stuff is and like if you move
over to a different region
the map you'll encounter like you know
sort of a polar
opposite yeah what you encountered
before even the way the map is like
designed in the game
looks like an amusement park style map
where it has like
big drawings of like here's the the
mothman building and here's the
you know the mill yeah
it does have a sort of fun like vibe to
it like you know there's a lot of
variety to be had
jonathan irwin wants to know can you aim
down your sights on your weapons like in
for
new vegas uh yes we totally did that
plenty you can probably check out
you know some footage right now
[Music]
uh ilo then that's how you say that yeah
uh wants to know what are we doing in
this game just loot and shoot or is
there an actual story
yeah there's a story um when you get
throughout when you get out the vault
they uh present a story where you're
trying to find the overseer of the vault
and
um as you're kind of following the clues
left behind of where the overseer went
you are
kind of like discovering the map and
learning new things and that seems to be
sort of the main story
in addition to that there are totally
side quests where you're learning what
happened to characters
um there are a couple interesting side
quests that i couldn't activate yet one
involving
uh mysterious like bunker so uh yes
there are totally side quests in the
game that you're doing with objectives
uh yeah daggody wants to know how often
would you say encounters with other
players are
it's kind of tough to say because we
were in a like
specific environment meant for like this
event
as opposed to like a public server and
also everyone was starting at the
beginning of the game
so there were a lot of players at the
very beginning it
definitely felt like a lot less players
near the
um once people started spreading it
spreading out and everyone's kind of
going to different locations
occasionally i would run into somebody
during some of the more like prominent
uh
locations on the map that people would
kind of gravitate towards but
it didn't feel like you're just
constantly running into people all the
time
or anything like that there are lots of
moments where it still felt like i was
on my own by myself yeah
even though we were in a group and we
sort of knew like where to go like where
to meet up with the other players like
um
we did encounter like some other players
not in our group like he was just
hanging out she's hanging out yeah cody
wants to know is there armor condition
yes there was conditioning for both
armor and weapons this time around uh
felt pretty good yeah and you have to
repair all your
materials at workbenches yep the
expander wants
to know a ton of stuff uh can strangers
access your base uh they cannot steal
stuff from your base
no can players pickpocket you no they
also want to know are cosmetic items
available only through microtransactions
no you uh do challenges in the game that
gets you
um these like they're called atomic or
like atoms
and you can use those points to get
cosmetics
so um they are also available through
micro transactions but you totally can
earn them
without microtransactions yeah george
webster has a few questions here
uh can you give us more details on the
crafting and survival aspects of the
game
well yes this game has a lot more you
know
focus on sort of maintaining your your
characters like you know
like conditions like you know it's very
similar to how it was presented in a
fallout 4's survival mode this is
basically like a
more advanced version of that you need
to eat
you need to drink water uh you need to
make sure you're not infected with any
diseases like uh
which we found well one one of which we
found was called rad worms
having those sort of ailments does sort
of sap your your character's health but
also your
ap points which is basically stamina so
it doesn't seem to outright
kill you like when i got real close to
my thirst being low and the game kind of
popped me up being like hey man
you're real thirsty you should drink
some water yeah it was called parched
harsh i was pushed
his other question was do you need caps
to craft items and use materials like in
fallout 4.
you definitely need to use materials but
uh caps bottle caps aren't like a
necessary part of that
from what we saw i don't think so it was
definitely more focused on
getting like all the junk items and
scrapping it so you can take all the
necessary components from them
right last question was what are some of
the coolest new items and weapons you
found in the game
uh coolest weapon i found was the heated
pitchfork which was a pitchfork with
like a propane tank that just
heated it up and then i could just like
scorching hot yeah that was definitely
the coolest thing i found yeah uh
we did found some other familiar fallout
weapons like the syringer from fallout 4
yep stuff like that um there was a high
level enemy that had something had a
tesla gun that looked really cool
we couldn't get it because he basically
killed us all with it yep uh we found a
crossbow but
uh you had to be level 15 to use it so i
could not use it
bowen orchid asks i've been wondering
how teams work um well
team is basically you know you walk up
to a player and you
ask you you just invite you there's a
button you just invite them to your team
uh there's also on the mapping like list
of like recent players and you can go
through that list
as a way to like invite people to your
team as well and it's
that's pulling from all the available
players on in the existing
like game space server yeah and uh up to
four players can team up at once
four players at once so it's pretty
simple with how it works um
as far as like interacting with each
other quest wise um
players can make their own pin points
they can start a quest that you can then
engage with if you want but you don't
have to
your quests don't have to be tied to
each other you can do your own separate
quests while
like the party leader is doing their own
thing although if you do their quest
um with them even if you don't have that
quest you actually still get the rewards
for it so that's a good thing so it's
still worth
even doing the request sometimes if you
want also you can fast travel to your
party members for
free it doesn't because normally in this
game it costs caps to fast travel
um that with your party members is
completely free so party members are a
good way to potentially like fast travel
around the map if you need to
uh khan plays wants to know are there
any guilds to join similar to the
brotherhood of steel or
the railroad uh we didn't see any guild
stuff
that at all but uh we did see some
familiar call outs to
brother steele yeah they mentioned the
brotherhood of steel
um you know stuff like that so i'm sure
those factions will all come into play
in some fashion in the story maybe but
we didn't uh there doesn't seem to be
any sort of like faction
specific mechanic yep a guy from newark
wants to know what happens when
another player kills you and they take
your stuff uh just to clear this up
they don't take any weapons or costumes
from you or they basically take
whatever junk items you have and junk
items are basically the items that
haven't been scrapped yet
yeah so all the stuff that you would use
to uh potentially
upgrade like your gear so if you're like
you know collecting a bunch of stuff to
upgrade a sweet weapon or something that
could be pretty devastating
sure absolutely especially if you
cleared out like a location null on your
own
yeah so there's definitely consequences
to getting killed but it's not quite
like oh now i
have literally nothing and i'm running
around naked or anything like that
diego d wants to know are players
visible on the map
yes um you can see most of all the
players like you know on the map
there's actually a list of like the
available yeah players you can pull up
there is
a if you crouch apparently they go away
from the map oh okay which
i didn't see an example of but that is
what the devs told us
and also um if there's a player a
particular player that's uh decided to
go rogue
and like basically attack uh other
players then they will very prominently
show up
they come up as a red star and that's
basically like you know
hey you know you can take them out and
get their you know bounty of
caps or whatever or just steer clear
them because they could be trouble
shadowstorm wants to know what the frame
rate is like on ps4 ps4 pro
xbox xbox one x and pcs with a gtx 1050
rtx card
that's very specific i imagine that's
the card they have on their computer
uh to answer your question we only
played the game on an xbox one x
and it was a bit spotty in our version
however it is an earlier build and they
were very clear about that
uh they said that um they are working on
getting the frame rate
up to a solid 30 for release um that is
what they're shooting
for and uh yeah hopefully they'll be
able to uh get that at launch yeah
john templeton wants to know what
content side levels would necessitate a
very strong
co-op help so he wants to know like uh
what stuff
pretty much almost requires co-op as
opposed to solo i think the majority of
stuff can be done solo there
do seem to be certain things that
require co-op um there are events that
kind of randomly pop up in the world
that are designed for multiple players
to go
and do that one you might not need to
party with though because
theoretically other players will just
sort of flock to that quest
it definitely seems like the scorch
piece will require uh some help
sure certain high level enemies although
you know maybe if you level up you could
do them
ethan wants to know will there be a way
to take other people's gear settlements
inventory and
quest items uh no you can't take any of
that stuff you can only take their
scraps yep
effects just wants to know uh what the
leveling system is gonna be like so
uh it's like you know all the other
fallout games you you know kill things
do quests
level up you uh get access to the
special system at which point you put
a point into one of those um you know
special system skills
and then um you have all these perk
cards that you kind of then get to uh
slot in
some perk cards require you to be a
certain level to use
and then every two levels you get access
to a card pack which gives you like a
bunch of random
perk cards support cards are kind of
like the main way that you're getting
stuff they kind of represent like
the way perks worked in you know the
other games abilities and stuff like
that
they also want to know am i going to
meet somebody level 100 who shoots me up
when i start up
so um no actually like the way the game
works is
they do like less damage to you um as
long as you don't engage them back so
for example i was level
eight and i i ran over to a level
uh like 59 player who
was eventually able to do some serious
damage to me but it took a bit
and like i was like in my menu just like
checking stuff my pit boy and they're
just shooting at me
and i was able to just um like fast
travel away from them yeah
so to answer your question like they'll
be uh they'll be able to grief on some
level but it's certainly not
to the point where um you're just gonna
have like a bad time
yeah and of course you can always block
players and like mute them yeah you can
block players and they just
they'll they won't be able to see you at
all yeah uh we are one says
uh they say it's a huge map uh but it's
is it actually filled with stuff or is
it just kind of sparse i would say it
was actually pretty stuffed with things
to do i felt like very dense yeah it was
very dense
um i i'm more impressed with the map
than i was with fallout 4's which i
found a little lacking in a lot of spots
um i felt like there was costly stuff to
do there was stuff to see
i felt like there was a really good
variety i'm so far i'm pretty happy with
how the map
uh is shaping up to be uh sebastian
wants to know how will melee weapons
work in bats um
it's very similar to you know how
shooting works
it's all in real time and uh you need to
be close enough to actually
get a clean hit on that it doesn't i
mean the way enemies move around a lot
it doesn't seem like a real viable way
to do it it was a bit disorienting too
because they're
moving around constantly yeah and you're
not getting like those cool like slow-mo
animations you're getting like three and
four so
honestly i would probably avoid bats
with melee yeah
garrett allen wants to know can we craft
ammo uh yes that's actually a big part
of sort of the game like you know you
need to you know
keep track of all your resources and in
a lot of cases you'll need to make some
um you know some really valuable like
stuff like ammo and like weapons yeah
and it's totally anything you can craft
yep
all right guys thank you for submitting
all of your questions hopefully that
answers what you guys wanted to know
about fallout 76
if you're curious about our personal
impressions we have a video that we did
about that
so go check that out and we have plenty
of gameplay of all 76 so go check that
out as well
[Music]
you